the ukr number went below one today so
inevitably talk has turned to loosening
lockdown
one source of inspiration is israel
which is now fully vaccinated more than
a quarter of its population
this chart of hospital emissions by age
in israel
shows that the vaccine might be having
an effect you can see
hospital emissions are falling faster in
the older vaccinated group
than they are in the younger
non-vaccinated group
working these things out is complex but
that might be
the vaccine protective effect trouble is
we haven't seen a similar effect in the
uk yet
here's hospital emission by emissions by
age in this country
you can see it's falling among all age
groups which is good
but it's falling at the same rate no
sign here of a vaccine effect
which is why the health secretary is
being cautious
it's clearly good news that the number
of cases is coming down
the plan is working but we're a long way
off
getting this sorted there's still over
25 000 people
in hospital with coronavirus right now
so everyone can have confidence that the
plan is working
what we're collectively doing together
is having a really positive impact
but there's still a long way to go there
are big differences of course between
israel and the uk
they're exclusively using the fisa
vaccine and they're given the second
dose after three weeks
and we're not and that's really
important these are the israeli criteria
for opening
gyms shops sporting and cultural events
and so on
we've got are below one but we are a
long way off having an equivalent of
three million people with a second dose
of the vaccine
at our current rate if it takes till may
but when i speak to scientists advising
the government
they are looking at another measure
apart from vaccines this
according to the office for national
statistics cases in the uk
are still very high and they're not
coming down
that fast the scientists are worried
because the more cases we have
the greater the risk is of new
vaccine-resistant variants
they want us to try and lower the level
of cases at least as low as this
when we came out the first lockdown of
course the prime minister might decide
differently
but based on the scientists advice it
does unfortunately look like this
lockdown
might have some way to go